bonsoir françois voulait mathis merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
une levée progressive et partielle en
tout cas c'est ce que soit la commission
européenne à partir du 1er juillet ou
bonne idée selon vous je crois qu'il
s'agit tout simplement d'essayer de
sauver au mois la saison touristique il
faut pas oublier quand même qu'une bonne
partie de l'europe toute l'europe du sud
en particulier est très affecté par
cette crise est particulièrement s'il
fallait envisager une fermeture des
frontières qui va au delà de la date
actuelle c'est-à-dire qui couvre les
vacances il s'agit donc essentiellement
d'essayer de sauver le touriste est si
vite sauvé les vacances qui sont une
source nécessaire est absolument
indispensable pour relancer l'économie
donc je crois que c'est une bonne idée
d'autant plus que tous les chiffres
montrent bon dans le même sens d'une
baisse du virus en europe
par contre la vigilance s'impose puisque
on le voit très bien en amérique le
coeur du virus est encore très actifs et
donc là des lames cette prudence est
nécessaire mais je crois qu'il faut
considérer deux périodes
il ya la période d'avant et pendant le
coït 19
c'est à dire la crise pendant laquelle
l'europe il faut bien de l'avouer a été
fondamentalement absente elle a été
fondamentalement impuissante et c'est
bien de ça qu'il s'agit de rattraper
aujourd'hui pourquoi la commission
européenne at-elle aujourd'hui pris les
devants pour essayer de proposer une
date
tout simplement parce qu'elle a
conscience qu'elle a été trop absente et
qu'il fallait maintenant qu'elle
reprenne un peu les rênes
alors vous l'avez dit dans le reportage
la commission n'est pas compétente pour
fixer une date d'ouverture des
frontières mais elle est compétente pour
essayer de donner avec autorité un
conseil qui lui devrait permettre
effectivement des rouvrir les frontières
au mois à partir du 1er juillet et en
respectant toutes les mesures
nécessaires alors le vice président
français or elle parle effectivement d'
approche commune entre et amendes on
vous l'avait bien expliqué il faut
essayer de fédérer tout ça ce qui a
manqué cruellement
ces dernières semaines est ce que ça
vous semble possible aujourd'hui avec le
spectacle qu'on nous a montré quand même
ces derniers mois alors je tire et
s'éteint c'est possible
une raison bien simple parce que les
pays européens ont agi seul
d'une certaine manière en décidant eux
mêmes les mesures qu'ils allaient
prendre pour lutter contre ce virus sur
leur territoire mais sont confrontés à
la perspective de demain et demain
malheureusement les états pris
individuellement vont être très désarmés
pour essayer de faire face à la crise
économique énorme épouvantable qui était
en train de se profiler
c'est pour faire face à cette crise
économique qui s'annonce
il n'y a pas 36 solutions les pays n'ont
pas de solution on le voit très bien
seul l'ensemble des pays européens qui
se coordonnent pouvoir trouver des
solutions pour financer en particulier
la banque centrale européenne n'a déjà
fait en dégageant un certain nombre de
milliards d'euros pour essayer de
débloquer les économies mais cela va
être nécessaire de continuer c'est sur
cette démarche
alors comment continuer bien tout
simplement en confirmant au niveau des
27 et non plus seul chaque pays pris
séparément la nécessité de mettre en
commun des actions qui doivent permettre
effectivement d'une part de faire face
éventuellement à un rebond du virus
et pour ça il faudra effectivement
éviter de reproduire les erreurs qu'on a
connus au début et puis d'autre part
pour préparer la suite c'est-à-dire
d'aider les économies de l'union
européenne d'aider à se redresser et ça
elles auront bien besoin
oui alors certaines plus que d'autres à
un certains pays ont plus souffert que
d'autres comment faire avaler justement
la pilule c'est l'éternel débat avec
l'europe de ce finalement qui ont
peut-être mieux gérer et donc moins
souffert là on a eu quand même petite
initiative qui n'est pas négligeable qui
est celle qui a été prise par le
président français emmanuel macron avec
angela merkel qui est d'accepter pour la
première fois pour les allemands c'est
vraiment une première d'accepter une
certaine forme de mutualisation des
dettes alors non pas des dettes
existantes mais de mutualiser les dettes
à venir en les dettes à venir elles vont
être considérables ça veut dire que pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'europe des pays qui sont relativement
riche
vont pouvoir accepter de mutualiser un
petit peu l'effort budgétaire avec des
pays qui eux ont subi de plein fouet la
crise et donc ça c'est véritablement une
première c'est une première marque qui
montre que l'europe est capable
finalement lorsqu'elle est mis au pied
du mur de trouver des solutions
concrètes pour essayer d'en sortir
l'italie s'était fortement plate au
début de la crise du cocan à virus vous
en souvenez de voir ce manque de
solidarité évidente de la part des
autres pays européens
aujourd'hui elle constate que l'ensemble
des pays européens de d'un certain
commun accord son accepte finalement de
faire un travail en commun c'est pas
encore gagné parce que l'histoire de
mutualisation de la dette il faut encore
obtenir l'accord des 27 qui n'est pas
encore totalement obtenu mais on est sur
une bonne voie d'autant plus qu' à la
couverture qui est importante de la
banque centrale européenne qui elle
accepte aujourd'hui de d'acheter de la
dette et acheter de la dette d'une
certaine manière c'est en partie
finalement la supprimer en partie
seulement alors réparer les dégâts
l'europe va s'y atteler donc préparer
l'avenir aussi vous l'aviez évoqué
rapidement un gala mais recalé emmanuel
macron qui a dans une lettre ont appelé
justement l'europe à préparer une
éventuelle nouvelle pandémie ça veut
dire quoi il faut revoir vraiment où
cette fois-ci agir d'un front commun au
niveau européen et plus état par état et
des erreurs qui ne faut pas en
reconnaître de nouveaux par exemple
celle de constater que dans certains
pays on manque cruellement de masques ou
alors des équipements d'urgence de
réanimateurs et c'est donc la
proposition de l'amptp qui semble tout à
fait naturel c'est de faire en sorte de
ensemble constitué un stock par exemple
provient première initiative constitue
un stock considérable de masques de
matériel de réanimation de matériels
médicaux et surtout de médicaments
éviter d'être sous la tutelle d'autres
pays et notamment pays asiatiques en ce
qui concerne la fabrication de
médicaments
ça c'est une urgence absolue et ça il
semble que là dessus
l'ensemble des pays soient d'accord pour
dire bombay il faut y aller et ça c'est
au niveau européen c'est pas au niveau
national qu il faudra se faire
et puis à la deuxième la deuxième étape
ce sera effectivement de se mettre en
commun pour la remise en route des
économies c'est de faire en sorte que
l'ouverture des frontières ne servent
pas à faire communiquer une virus b
servent à communiquer des marchandises
ces règles à faire communiquer entre
elles et les économies pour que les
économies des différents thés des 27
pays de l'union européenne puisse
véritablement redémarré parce qu'ils
sont en très mauvaise posture en ce
moment merci beaucoup françois pour les
mathis jardin et spécialiste de l'europe
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse